like you i was desperately hoping for
some glad festive tidings when it came
to the covert data but i'm afraid well
it just came in uh and it looks a little
bit worrying when you look at these dots
they basically show you just the number
of cases that we're hearing about each
day positive test results and i'll
highlight it look 106 122 new cases when
you look at a seven day average which is
probably the best way to do it because
it can be quite volatile that line's
basically vertical at the moment here's
the good news when we just look across
the uk because of course cases is one
thing what really really matters uh when
it comes to this is hospital admissions
and deaths and when you look at
admissions well there was a pattern last
time around i put it on a different axis
by the way that red line but there was a
pattern in the first wave but look
what's happened since those lines have
diverged and even though that line that
black line is vertical the red line is
still pretty low which is quite
encouraging but here's the thing we
really need to look into the hot spots
of where there is covered right now in
particular omicron and we can do that if
we have a look at this map and look at
the areas that are the most red and
black that's where the most covert is
and if we zoom in you can probably just
see london you've got a lot of covert
right now in london just look at that
black line that's basically showing you
in comparison uh with the last wave and
again it's basically vertical um look at
emissions that's the blue line that is
rising slightly faster than you would
have hoped at the moment about nine
percent uh a day so the question is what
happens next death's still very low uh
reassuring but of course it's early days
uh with that black line it takes a while
to see that feed through i'm going to
show you this in a different way so
again same data so it's for london we're
looking at cases and what we're going to
do is we're going to compare what
happened in the alpha wave so this is
last december remember that wave the
kent variant as we call it that's how it
rose but now look at omicron and we're
just comparing the shapes look at how
much steeper that line is so you're
seeing many more cases this time around
and now compare hospitalizations so
hospital admissions last time around
this is what they look like uh in the
first few weeks of the alpha wave again
so this is the last winter that line but
now the red line is this time around and
you can see it's broadly following it
some people would have hoped that that
red line might be below
the black line but still consider the
chart on the left much steeper rise uh
in cases this time around so
hospitalization's much more shallow and
if we look at certain parts hot spots
within the hot spots so if we look at
lambeth if we look at city of london you
can look at wandsworth as well you're
seeing similar charts to this kind of
way higher in terms of the number of
cases again this is cases than we saw
last time but if you zoom in might there
be a little [ __ ] of light here little
sign of hope zoom in here we're looking
at this same data but on a logarithmic
axis and you can just about make out in
the top right hand side it might well be
starting to decelerate at the moment
that
is in lambeth where we're seeing kind of
the most uh covered at the moment and if
you take a step back have a look at this
this shows you test positivity lots of
testing happening right now and some
people have been asking whether those
previous lines i've been showing you are
they just down to the fact that we're
testing much more at the moment well
this adjusts for that because it's
positive tests as a percentage of all
tests done and in england the red line
and in scotland you can see both of
those are basically vertical and we're
probably going to see a lot more case
growth in the next few weeks the big
question is what happens to
hospitalizations